in the opening scene we are introduced
to a young girl by the name of Maria
Maryweather who is attending her
father's funeral she notices a boy in
the distance but he vanishes when she
takes a second look after the funeral
Maria and her caretaker heliotrope
heliotrope visit their lawyer's office
to hear about her father's final will it
turns out that her father lost all the
property leaving her with only one
possession a book titled the ancient
Chronicles of moon acre Valley later
that evening Maria reads the book which
has a story of a young woman who is
beloved by nature one night this woman
was blessed with magical Moon pearls
which turned her into a Moon Princess
belonging to the denoir clan she fell in
love with a man named Rolf from the
Merryweather Clan at her wedding the
princess's Father William denoir
presented the couple with a rare black
lion while the groom gifted his bride a
beautiful unicorn filled with happiness
the Moon Princess decided to tell them
about the moon pearls she disclosed that
those pearls can reveal the truth in a
man's heart and that it can grants any
wish hearing the Revelation the two
families appeared to be possessed by
greed at this point Maria closes the
book and decides to rest for the night
in the next scene helot Trope brings
Maria to moonacre Manor to live with her
EST stranged Uncle sir Benjamin
Merryweather on their way they almost
get abducted by some Bandits including
the one whom Maria saw earlier however
Maria and helot Trope managed to fight
back and Escape after traveling for a
while they finally arrive at their
destination they're welcomed by Maria's
strict looking Uncle who expresses his
condolences towards her father then
heliotrope tries to share their
encounter with the bandits but Benjamin
shows no interest in hearing her
fascinating Tales he leads them inside
and introduces them to his big black dog
named Ralf following this he directs the
two of of them to their respective rooms
the following morning Maria takes her
inherited book in hand and heads
downstairs for breakfast Benjamin
notices the book and seizes it to keep
in his Library Maria tries to protest
but her uncle ignores her during
breakfast heliotrope tries to strike up
some chitchat but Benjamin asks her to
keep quiet as he prefers silence while
eating Maria again asks him to return
her book as it was left to her by her
father in response Benjamin addresses
her dad as a coward which enrages Maria
regardless he goes on to express his
dissatisfaction towards her father as he
lost everything to gambling afterwards
Benjamin provides a tour of the house
during which Maria inquires about the
bandits from earlier he discloses that
the bandits were from the denoir clan
and warns Maria to steer clear of the
forest later on Maria is wandering
around the Mansion when she comes across
a piano that plays on its own intrigued
she follows the moving keys and begins
to to play a beautiful Melody shortly
after Benjamin spots her and he doesn't
appear to be happy at all in fact Old
Uncle Benji boy looks like he's got a
stick up his ass in the evening Benjamin
teaches Maria how to ride a horse after
imparting some basic instruction Maria
gets on a white horse and the two make
their way out to explore the village as
Twilight approaches Benjamin suggests
returning home but Maria seems to be
enjoying the ride as a result she
expresses her wish to stay out for a
little longer prompting Benjamin to
leave her on her own while Riding Solo
Maria hears a distressed cry so she
Ventures into the forest disregarding
her uncle's warning there she comes
across a trapped rabbit and proceeds to
rescue it just then she is surrounded by
a group of Bandits one of them is the
same boy from the earlier scenes named
Robin denoir they intend to abduct her
but just before that the intimidating
Rolf appears and frightens them away
after this Maria carries the injured
rabbit home that same night she
experiences a strange vision of a white
horse Galloping outside the Mansion
leaving her in shock the next day Maria
approaches Benjamin with a series of
questions about the peculiar things
happening in the place such as the
enigmatic White Horse and the piano that
plays on its own Benjamin for some
reason turns around with watery eyes and
asks if she'll ever stop asking
questions a short while later Rolf leads
her to the mansion's kitchen where she
meets with the manner's magical Chef
named marmaduk he has the ability to
teleport from one place to another and
is extremely fast with his work when
Maria inquires about the unusual
happenings marmaduk advises her to
complete her reading of her father's
book in addition he helps her in
retrieving the book from Benjamin's
Library when Maria finally continues
reading the book she learns that the two
families fought over the pearls seeing
their greed left the moon Prin princess
upset so she cursed moonacre Valley to
be plunged into Eternal Darkness at the
rising of the 5,000th Moon unless a pure
heart is heard realizing that the story
is based on real life Maria rushes to
marmaduk who confirms that the place is
falling apart because of the curse
according to him only a true Moon
Princess can undo the curse Maria is
confused as the Moon Princess had lived
hundreds of years ago but marmaduk
discloses that a pure heart can see a
white unicorn and the one with this
ability is a true Moon Princess hearing
this Maria learns that she is the chosen
one regardless she isn't ready to
believe it and as a result she decides
to run away from the mansion and fair
enough this unicorn is a lot to
handle on her way through the woods
Maria stumbles upon a cave inhabited by
a woman named love day who Bears a
striking resemblance to the Moon
Princess from the book love day invites
Maria into her home and discloses that
she herself was once a moon princess she
encourages Maria to stay emphasizing
that she cannot escape from what she's
meant to do in response Maria admits
that she'd like to help but she doesn't
even know where to begin love day tells
her to find the moon pearls because
nobody knows where they are that's not
helpful it turns out that the denoir
stole the casket containing the pearls
and the merryweathers took the key to it
hearing this Maria suddenly realizes
that the bookmark she's been using
contains a hidden key with this missing
key Maria asks love day to take her to
the denoir so that she can retrieve the
moon pearls from the casket as per her
request Lov day shows her dair's
Fortress but abruptly refuses to go any
further saying that she can never go
back there Maria understands her worries
and decides to go alone following this
she sneaks into the Fortress but is soon
spotted by Robin's father kurir being
caught she surrenders the key to him but
he reveals that the casket is empty
Maria believes that they've hidden them
but he claims that they were never in
the casket and accuses the merryweathers
of stealing them moreover Kur says that
when Eternal darkness comes the do noirs
will finally rise and the merryweathers
will be punished for their treachery and
greed after this Maria is imprisoned in
a dungeon that c denir is a real ass
deole the following morning Maria uses
her gown to deceive the guard into
opening her cellor when he does so she
seizes the opportunity to make an escape
through the woods upon learning about
her Escape Kur orders his men to execute
her as he doesn't want to stop the curse
Maria is then chased by Robin and his
men but she manages to outrun them by
hiding in the forest at the same time
Rolf finds her and leads her home upon
arriving Benjamin berates her for her
irresponsible act Maria tries to explain
herself but her uncle isn't ready to
listen later that night Benjamin regrets
his hurtful actions so he comes to
Maria's door to apologize he does so and
clarifies that he did it all because he
was worried for her Maria does not reply
but she appears to be heartened by his
loving gestures at the break of dawn
Maria hears some noise outside her room
prompting her to swiftly grasp a
Candlestick and hide behind the
fireplace just then love day enters her
room through a secret door Maria
expresses her dissatisfaction towards
love day for abandoning her earlier in
response love Day offers her apologies
and presents the moon princess's attire
Maria also forgives her and proceeds to
try the outfit on with the two appearing
identical they head downstairs after a
while love day is drawn to the sound of
the piano and rushes to the music room
to play it amidst this Maria notices a
mirror in the room upon gazing into it
she sees a glimpse of Benjamin and love
day as a loving couple it is then
revealed that Benjamin and love day were
about to get married however things took
an unexpected turn when love day
disclosed that she's a denoir and that
she has been feigning to be a
Merryweather this Revelation enraged
Benjamin who then accused her of
tricking him to fall in love with her as
a result Benjamin broke off the
engagement and love day ran away later
Maria notices a hous helper named dig
weed removing a painting of the Moon
Princess that appeared out of nowhere
she asks him to stop and then shows the
painting to heliotrop and marmaduk as
they stare at it the Moon Princess
reveals a tree in which the moon pearls
are hidden with this information in hand
Maria decides to seek help from Robin
who knows every knok and corner of the
forest before setting off she sends
forged letters to Benjamin and love day
convincing them to meet that afternoon
Benjamin and love day reunite after an
extended separation both appearing
joyful however they soon discover
Maria's deception when they both expect
to apologize to each other following
this the two accompanied by heliotrope
marmaduk and digweed Embark in search of
Maria on the other hand K learns through
his Spy Eagle that Maria is in the
forest prompting him and his associates
to set out in pursuit of her meanwhile
Maria meets Robin in the forest and
traps him with the help of a rope
suspending him upside down the young boy
pleads with her to release him and Maria
agrees on the condition that he listens
to her she asks him to help percate the
moon pearls Robin hesitates as he is
prohibited from helping the
merryweathers and his father has
instructed him to carry out her
execution however Maria convinces him
saying that they have limited time or
else the entire Valley will die with her
together they then make their way toward
the tree containing the moon pearls on
their way one of K's henchmen grabs
Robin from behind separating him from
Maria he is then brought before his
father who is infuriated by Robin's
perceived betrayal Trail but for I did
it for zi core claims that he no longer
trusts Robin and vows to take the matter
into his own hands left alone Maria
calls out for Rolf who is also missing
before long she has a vision of the same
White Horse which leads her to the tree
housing the moon pearls but just before
entering she is apprehended by Kur who
demands that she guide him to the Moon
pearls elsewhere Robin manages to escape
his captors with the help of rol but as
they're running away Rolf sadly gets
shot by K's men and this claims his life
just then Robin hears Maria's scream so
he follows the sound he finally finds
her and rescues her from his father
Maria and Robin then head towards the
tree and enter a hollow opening in
between the roots upon entering they
finally find the moon pearls moments
before K's men arrive there the duo
escaped through a secret tunnel the moon
pearls and the glimpses of the White
Horse guide them out out on the other
hand Kur reaches a cliff where the
valley was cursed soon after Benjamin
arrives with his servants who are Then
followed by Maria and Robin Maria shows
the moon pearls but prevents anyone from
touching them she asserts that greed and
pride were the root causes of both
families suffering despite this Kur and
Benjamin once again engage in a heated
dispute until love day intervenes here
it is revealed that love day is in fact
K's daughter she confronts her father
questioning why he has such a deep
hatred inside of him she tries to
convince both Benjamin and her father to
set aside their pride and break the
curse however the two of them still
stand on their ego seeing this Maria
realizes that she must do it by herself
as a result she walks to the edge of the
cliff and jumps into the sea with the
pearls as The Moon Rises a huge wave
surges towards the cliff with hundreds
of white horses running in it Maria
appears a top one of these horses which
carries her back to the group seeing her
back Benjamin is relieved and he
Embraces her with tears in his eyes as
the curse dissolves Rolph is also
revived and he assumes his true form the
black lion finally Benjamin and love day
reconcile with the former offering
apologies for his stubborn Pride the
movie ends with the Merryweather and the
denir families coming together and
moonacre Valley finally restored to its
former glory subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching